we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors if you're trying to quit
smoking or vaping check out lucy which
is a nicotine gum developed by caltech
scientists they'll ship it right to your
door and you can save 20
when you go to lucy.co and use coupon
code pacman
magic spoon is the cereal that tastes
exactly like the delicious cereals from
your childhood except it has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect
for a keto diet to get free shipping go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman blinkist
is the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free and get
25
off a subscription by going to
blinkist.com
david pakman i'm going to start today
with something
very pithy and simple
that i know is going to get some of my
audience
upset with me and that's okay because we
can disagree i think
which is that barack obama former
president
was right to say that the defund the
police slogan
is not a good slogan and that it needs
to be completely
renamed and i'm actually reminded of the
ronald reagan quote
if you are explaining you were losing
ronald reagan was correct
and republicans seem to get this this is
one of the biggest failures of the left
if you look at the
at the work of uh people like thomas
frank and
and george lakoff in particular about
naming and framing and slogans the left
is
absolutely terrible at this and when you
have to
explain well when i said defund i meant
this other thing
you're already losing so let's kind of
go through it in layers
actually defunding and eliminating the
police as a big picture plan
doesn't make any sense it we've talked
about this before
it's not reasonable it's not practical
it's not going to happen in any
uh framework that we can imagine
even places that quote have done it
haven't really done it sometimes they've
just
separated up police departments into
different subgroups or units or whatever
the case may be
now some people are saying defund the
police but they mean something else
they mean um you know will reform
mostly in some places will have fewer
police in others will demilitarize and
will change how prosecution is done well
now you're explaining away a slogan that
doesn't really represent
what you mean so why are you using the
slogan anyway
and i've been talking about this since
day one of this
slogan during the george floyd protests
i put
out like a 10 or 12 point plan for how i
would reform the police
and many in my audience agreed with
demilitarization
training as social workers extending
police training periods
stopping what i call low effort policing
it's a very long list which you can go
back to and there were some in my
audience who furiously did not agree
with me
and i presume that those same folks
aren't going to like what barack obama
said
so what did barack obama say let's take
a look at that if
you believe as as i do that we should be
able to reform the criminal justice
system
so that it's not biased and treats
everybody
fairly i guess you can use a snappy
slogan like
defund the police but you know you've
lost a big audience the minute you say
it which makes it a lot less likely that
you're actually going to get the changes
you want done
but if you instead say let's reform the
police department
so that everybody's being treated fairly
you know divert
young people from getting into crime and
if there's a homeless guy
can maybe we send a mental health worker
there instead of
an armed unit that could end up
resulting in a tragedy
suddenly a whole bunch of folks who
might not otherwise listen to you
are listening to you so the key is
deciding do you want to actually get
something done
or do you want to feel good among the
people you already agree with
and if you want to get something done in
a democracy
in a country as big and diverse as ours
then you've got to be able to
meet people where they are and play a
game of addition and not subtraction
this is simply pragmatism and barack
obama actually lists many of the exact
same reforms that i suggested in my list
some months ago
barack obama's making the exact same
case that i made about actually getting
things done that's what i care about i
want to get things done
think about it in those terms there are
millions of people in the united states
who believe the police should be
reformed and you even have
allies on areas of the right on that
idea
you have some on the libertarian right
who want to reform the drug policing
piece of police departments you have
some on the religious
right that want community programs
rather than prison for certain crimes
you have people like me on the left who
want to end the war on drugs
and and police militarization and solve
the problem of it being so difficult to
hold bad
actors accountable due to a system that
favors police when they're charged with
crimes and prevents this global
national bad actors database you know
all these different things you have all
these
different people who could conceivably
work together on this
and then you have a tiny portion of
people who actually just want police
flatly defunded and eliminated in some
cases
so if what you mean by defund
is the things i mentioned and the things
that barack obama mentioned
then you simply lose potential allies
when the slogan is defund the police
and the police so i just don't have time
when things are so critical to be toying
around with slogans that are going
nowhere anyway
defund the police sounds like you're
saying
we should take funding away from police
who are bad
and do away with police as an
institution now
some people do think that if you're
somebody who thinks that
we just disagree most people don't think
that
they think something closer to my reform
plan
so by using the slogan you're
immediately trying to explain what you
really mean and that means that you're
losing
let me give you one further example one
of the things we need
are police officers from more diverse
backgrounds
and i'm not talking you know racially or
religiously or economically even
although that would be good
i'm talking culturally you find that in
many
cities police are disproportionately
from conservative rural areas
outside the city one thing that will
help
fix police is more people who would do
the job the way
we want them to do the to do the job
people who are from and even live in
those cities now
typically the cities are more expensive
than the rural areas
so sometimes police being underpaid
and not being able people in cities
can't live in the cities on a police
salary
that's why you get people from the rural
conservative areas
coming in because they can come in and
then live in the cheaper areas
you might have to increase funding in
those cases for salaries
to get more cultural diversity in the
police department so
how does defund the police help achieve
that it doesn't
now there's a reasonable counterpoint
from uh
people including congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez
who says you don't start with the safe
ask
you start with more and you negotiate
back
the problem with that is specifically
with a slogan like defund the police
tons of people tune out because it
sounds wacky it's not like hey listen
we'd like 22 bucks an hour
so we'll ask for it and we'll negotiate
down to 15 because everybody will
participate in the negotiation no it's
not
we would love medicare for all but we
would
negotiate to a strong public option to
start
and then next year we come back with
medicare for all if you want to get rid
of police altogether
you immediately get a rejection from a
lot of the people that are
in the reform and they see you as a
non-serious actor
and it stops the conversation so yes i
agree with president obama
i think he's absolutely right here and
we're going to damage our own ability to
fix the problems
that we've identified by using slogans
like defund when it's not what most
people mean and it's never going to
happen anyway
tell me where i'm wrong i'm ready to
have a bigger discussion about it
joe biden has made another cabinet
selection it's a very important one
because it is the secretary of health
and human services
who will be coming in during a global
hundred-year pandemic and it turns out
that joe biden has selected someone
who has long supported medicare for all
this is very interesting it's a big deal
and it is xavier becerra who has been
chosen
to lead joe biden's department of health
and human services now back in 2017
uh when when he was also california
attorney general as he still is
becerra said he would quote absolutely
support
a medicare-for-all plan becerra will
be leaving his post as california
attorney general
he will be a huge part of fighting the
coronavirus pandemic he will be a very
welcome replacement to the clownish
trump secretary of hhs alex azar who is
just
a wild trump brown noser now
from the standpoint of identity there is
another first
xavier becerra would be the first latino
to run hhs
we're expecting more more health related
announcements from joe biden very very
soon we found out about some of them
i mentioned already secretary of hhs
will be
xavier becerra at the cdc it will be
rachelle wilenski the mass general
hospital chief of infectious disease
here in boston
surgeon general will be dr vivek murthy
who was also barack obama's
surgeon general so these are solid
choices qualified people
now i admit what does not make sense
to me about choosing xavier becerra for
secretary of hhs
is that he does lack experience in the
area of health and medicine he's a
lawyer
now there's a counterpoint to that now
it's great that xavier becerra has
supported medicare for all
i see a lot of bernie people who like
the choice for that reason
but he does lack experience in the field
of medicine on the other hand he has
been front and center
as a lawyer fighting for obamacare and
as i imagine we will see as soon as joe
biden is sworn in
republicans go right back to let's get
rid of obamacare let's get rid of
obamacare even though we have no
replacement
in that sense becerra is a good choice
uh but remember that
you know biden doesn't support medicare
for all anyway
but he does want to expand the
affordable care act to include a public
option and becerra has experience
defending
the aca in uh uh legal settings
and um the the other important aspect of
this is that
the truth is that secretary of hhs
you're not really making
medical decisions you're really an
executive
managing the apparatus of health and
human services and in that sense there's
no way to argue
that becerra is unqualified now
hilariously there are some republicans
who have immediately said
uh becerra's a radical he's a radical we
can't we can't have him running hhs
and of course you know those those
guidelines
for what counts as radical at this point
have been completely cartoonified by the
right
this also by the way takes xavier
becerra off the list to be the
replacement for kamal harris
whose senate seat will be vacated when
she becomes a vice president
and that's another story which we'll be
covering and and
lastly there is a good chance that
becerra will have a tough confirmation
fight in the senate i think he will be
confirmed because ultimately he's
completely qualified
but i think it has the potential to get
quite ugly
let me know what you think about this
selection i'm on twitter at d
pacman i'd love to hear from you the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
caltech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice flavor
lucy is affordable it'll ship right to
your door you don't have to go out to
the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away and get rid of the
vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.com i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just
a quick disclaimer i'm required to give
these products contain
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that our program is mostly
funded by
members who sign up at joinpackman.com
you'll get commercial free audio and
video streams of the show as well as the
daily bonus show
the bonus show is an extra show every
day
just for our members it's a beautiful
thing
sign up at joinpacman.com for me
popularity contests are not a good way
to measure the worth of anything
i think we need to think more deeply
more critically to find out whether
something is good or bad
a valuable or worthless worth doing or
not worth doing but there's a big
contingent that supports donald trump
uh as well as to donald trump personally
to whom everything is popularity it's
approval rating
it's the size of trump's crowd it's that
type of thing and along these lines
is a very triggering poll for donald
trump which has already been released
and it shows that
joe biden is already weeks before taking
office
more popular than donald trump has ever
been during his entire presidency the
numbers are really stunning
gallup has been tracking presidential
approval
for decades both during transition
periods
and presidencies and joe biden's
approval has risen to 55
already and this is a number that trump
has never reached
during his entire presidency trump never
got to 50
and is currently dipped down to 42
approval
while joe biden has jumped to 55 and
something
very interesting are the sort of
internals of these numbers how they're
made up
in terms of party where we see that over
the month from mid-october to
mid-november
biden's approval among republicans
doubled
the numbers are still low but it doubled
from 6 to 12.
biden's approval among independents is
up 7 points 48 to 55
and it's basically unchanged changed
among democrats because it was already
at 95 percent it went to 96.
now donald trump's approval also hasn't
changed among democrats it's at three
percent
it was at three percent before and it's
at three percent now independent
approval of trump is almost unchanged
down two points
but trump among republicans has lost six
points of approval so there's a few
important aspects to this story
number one trump has been and remains a
historically unpopular president
trump is the outlier here typically the
president-elect
gets a bump when they're awaiting
inauguration trump never got that back
in november of 2016
december of 2016 and and the first part
of january 2016.
and in the end that's not really
surprising because in 2016 remember that
donald trump
won electorally with the biggest
popular vote loss of anything we've seen
for a winning
president but there's actually more to
this the reason i care about this
is not just trump will be triggered okay
what we have right now is a situation
where we will be changing
federal leadership in the middle of the
absolute worst moment in the united
states of a global hundred year pandemic
the importance of joe biden building
goodwill with as
many people in the united states as
possible can't possibly be overstated
and if biden's approval has already
jumped to 55
presumably at least some of it because
joe biden
formed a coronavirus task force has
actually provided some parallel
leadership to trump when it comes to the
virus
has announced he'll be bringing on
anthony fauci as chief medical advisor
hopefully people are seeing
the approach of biden and are reacting
to it with goodwill
because on day one joe biden is going to
have to spring into action now
of course unj biden will be inaugurated
january 20th
you know and i know that on january 21st
january 23rd
maybe at the latest republicans will
start blaming biden for coronavirus
deaths
even though of course all of this has to
do with the federal failure to start
testing and deal with this seriously at
the beginning
uh cases and deaths reflect activity
weeks and months prior okay we already
know that
but on day one joe biden is going to
come in and he's going to say
let's listen to the science and medical
community um
and if we see joe biden spike to maybe
60
approval or 62 hopefully he will get as
much of the country as possible on board
with working together to deal with the
virus
that's the top priority right now
presidents come and go
tracking approval rating is not very
important in the abstract but right now
we've had as many as 230 000 coronavirus
cases in a day
we're starting to see days with 3 000
deaths
we are starting to see vaccines
hopefully rolling out this month
presidential approval actually right now
connects with saving lives
in that it will signal buy-in with what
incoming president joe biden will likely
be asking people to do
including wearing masks when he's sworn
in and yes
the optics of highly triggerable
popularity obsessed trump already being
outdone by joe biden's
approval before biden is even president
i do admit that it's funny in a sense
but it also is very important
on to vaccines now this is really a
great
decision that pfizer and moderna have
made
pfizer and moderna have turned down
donald trump's invitation to a
propaganda vaccine summit scheduled for
today at the white house
and i have to tell you seeing this makes
me more confident in these vaccines not
that i wasn't already confident but this
increases to me as a signal that pfizer
and moderna as the manufacturers of the
first two coronavirus vaccines expected
in the u.s very soon
they are staying away from political
optics when it comes to the vaccine
trump is doing by the time you listen to
today's show
he may already have done it a vaccine
summit
at the white house to take credit for
these vaccines
trump will be there pence will be there
there will be other private sector
executives there including people
involved
sort of in the logistics of the shipping
and distribution of these vaccines
it certainly is being interpreted as an
event
meant to pressure the fda to quickly
approve these vaccines
it's a political event to put political
pressure on the fda
and both pfizer and moderna have said no
thanks we're not going to go
we know that the fda commissioner
stephen hahn has been called to the
white house at least two times
almost like being called to the
principal's office to explain
why aren't you approving these vaccines
more quickly so we know that the white
house is very anxious to see that happen
so there's a few good things here first
of all good for pfizer and moderna they
are developing a vaccine
they're going through the process for
approval they are opting out of this
political charade
and that makes me more confident that
they are doing things the right way now
cnbc
was saying the official reason that they
aren't participating
is that they have vaccine approval
pending before the fda
so that it would not be ethical or
appropriate for pfizer and moderna to
appear
with the fda at what is a political
propaganda
event moderna put out a statement very
carefully worded which said
we don't have an ideological objection
to being there
but when we learned the agenda of the
meeting
we realized our participation isn't
required
and that's such a narrowly and carefully
worded public relations statement that
it really doesn't change the
understanding of why they're not going
to be there for me
but the bottom line is the optics of the
vaccine manufacturer
and the regulatory agency that will be
deciding about that vaccine's approval
being there together at what is a
political dog and pony show
it wouldn't be good so they're making
the right decision secondly
the uh optics of attending
would fuel the idea that donald trump
had something to do with these vaccines
when in fact
he did not them not attending pfizer and
moderna
is also good for that reason although
trump's sycophants will think that this
is the trump vaccine
anyway and you know what i don't care if
it convinces them to get vaccinated
they can think whatever they want think
if you'll go and get the vaccine because
you believe it to be the trump vaccine
have at it hoss we all benefit from you
going and getting vaccinated
but now and this is the really big
explosive story
we have learned that pfizer may have
extra reason not to attend which is that
we learned yesterday that over the
summer
pfizer went to the trump administration
and gave them an option to buy
and secure more doses of their vaccine
trump refused and now donald trump is
demanding more production from pfizer
even though he turned down more doses
let's talk about that next
this is truly horrible it it there's
just no other way to say it
we learned yesterday that the trump
administration passed they said no
thanks
when pfizer in late summer offered to
sell them more vaccine doses from this
initial tranche
that is now starting to be delivered we
are already seeing
uh british citizens vaccinated in the uk
so i really need you to understand
what's going on here in the last few
days we learned
pfizer may not be able to get as many
doses to the united states as we had
hoped beyond these initial doses and
it's now believed
that after this initial set of doses
that is
already uh being delivered in advance of
approval that is expected soon
we are not expecting for the us to get
more pfizer vaccine doses
until june of 2021. what
what on earth june of 2021 how is that
possible
it's possible because when the trump
administration
said no thanks to pfizer about buying
extra doses in late summer pfizer
offered them to other countries
other countries that said yes one
example is the uk again the uk
is already vaccinating people it's just
blunder after blunder and these are
deadly
blunders i mean quite literally how many
extra people will die
because we will be vaccinating fewer
people with the pfizer vaccine
as a result of trump turning down
purchasing more doses
so now trump is panicked trump is
scrambling
to try to force pfizer into selling
these doses to the united states
trump haphazardly and desperately has
put together an executive order that he
might sign today or tomorrow
which is quote to ensure that the u.s
government prioritizes getting the
vaccine to american citizens
before it goes to other nations it's not
at all clear
with regard to enforcement mechanisms
what it is that that executive order
would even do
pfizer has sold doses to other countries
because trump turned them down
i would call it a comedy of errors
except there's nothing funny about it
it's more like a tragedy of errors
deadly errors and in the meantime not
only is the united kingdom already
vaccinating people
the european union has reached a deal
with pfizer for 200 million doses with
an option for 100 million more
now when asked about this the trump
administration spokeswoman for hhs said
quote we are going to get the 100
million we agreed on
and listen in any case there are five
other possible vaccines
so they're essentially admitting yeah
we're not likely to get more than just
that first tranche
of vaccines from pfizer but we're sort
of counting on other vaccines anyway
and understand that the other vaccines
other than the moderna one are not
likely to be approved anytime soon so it
is just
pathetic misstep after misstep by this
administration now let's think of the
why
why would trump turn down vaccine doses
the only thing i can think of
is the pfizer vaccine wasn't funded by
operation warp speed
is it possible that trump is so
self-centered
so narcissistic where he didn't want to
commit to more doses
because pfizer wasn't an operation warp
speed participant
because at the same time even though
pfizer didn't participate in operation
warp speed
trump and his staffers have been taking
credit for it anyway so why would that
stop them
so the trajectory now is given that we
will not have that many doses of the
pfizer vaccine
uh the trajectory optimistically would
be with pfizer
and modernist vaccine we would have
enough supply
over the next six months to vaccinate
about a hundred million americans
that's a little under a third of the
population
there's the possibility of getting a
hundred million doses total
remember two doses per person so 100
million would be for 50 million people
from the oxford johnson and johnson and
novavax vaccine options we don't know
when those will be approved or what
availability will be
it's also lower efficacy as of right now
but we might be able to get
50 million more people vaccinated with
those so that puts us at
optimistically 100 million people
vaccinated maybe by april oh april 1st
maybe may 1st starts getting warmer
we would have about 30 vaccination plus
five percent people
with natural immunity from having the
virus although we don't know
how long that immunity lasts 35 ish
going into the summer more people
outdoors
um a few less spread and more vaccines
coming forward so it it still does seem
as though it's plausible
that the second half of 2021 will be
looking much better than now
do you think i'm being too optimistic
based on the numbers we have
let me know in either case it will be
very good to have donald trump gone in
six weeks
we will have more coverage of this on
the show's
instagram which is at david pakman show
you can also find a loony wacky
unhinged hate mail i got today on my
instagram david.pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100
of your money if you don't love it no
questions asked
go to magicspoon.com pacman to build
your own
custom variety box today make sure to
use promo
code pacman to get free shipping the
link is right underneath this video
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today charles whelan who is professor of
public policy
at dartmouth author of a number of books
many of which i've read including naked
economics naked money naked statistics
uh great to have you on today great i'm
glad you've read all the naked books
that's how we refer to this series
so uh you taught well in the books you
talk a lot
particularly in naked economics and
naked money
about the impact and repercussions at a
macroeconomic level
of the government doing things which
include making adjustments to the money
supply
making money available in different ways
so maybe to pick something that's going
on now when you look at
the so-called coronavirus stimulus and
how that was administered partially to
individuals partially as loans partially
to corporations
what about it from a broad economic
standpoint was done correctly and what
was not so good
i think the best thing is that it put
money in the pockets
of people who needed it small businesses
and we'll get to how well it was
targeted because that anticipates i
think one of the weaknesses
and also consumers who are at risk of
missing rent payments being evicted
and the like one of the most intriguing
concepts in economics is the
paradox of thrift this idea that when
something
bad happens our natural and entirely
rational
response is to spend less to hang on to
what we have and of course as soon as we
hang on to what we have then we don't
buy a refrigerator don't buy a car don't
go out to dinner
and that's the income of all of those
folks they hang on more tightly and of
course more businesses
are in distress so somehow government
needs to overcome
that paradox of thrift now in the
financial crisis
the problem was that all our financial
institutions were paralyzed
nobody could get credit if you want to
go to a restaurant the restaurant was
open but the
you know how can we open the spigots of
credit again
so the economy worked with covid we've
got an entirely different problem the
banking system is mercifully healthy
and many people went into covid in
pretty good financial shape
but they couldn't spend the money they
had because the restaurant was closed
so the challenge there was to keep those
restaurants afloat
until we could get through and i guess
we're now seeing the end of the tunnel
the pandemic just keep them afloat as
opposed to starting up say the financial
system again
yeah it seems when i look at the way
some european countries and other
countries handled this
they were more aggressive with the idea
of we will pay the salaries of your
employees
so that you don't lay anybody off i
think the idea being that there would be
less friction
in getting things back up to speed
because the the employees would still be
employees and and so on
do you think that that was not done well
enough in the us
i think our approach was probably a
little more scatter shot
some of the payments to businesses had
the effect of keeping employees
on the books on the other end i talked
to small business people
who faced a dilemma whereby if they were
kept
on at reduced salary their employees
might have done better if they went on
unemployment
right and so you created some kind of
tension there and then obviously what
we've been reading in the news in the
last couple weeks about
a high proportion of these payments
going to a small number of firms
i haven't delved into that but that does
get to
a question you always have to face which
is how well targeted
is this to the folks who really need
support
in the near term that's priority number
one primary priority number two is
how well targeted is it to the folks who
will continue to spend in ways that keep
other businesses healthy and what what
are the answers to those two questions
as far as
somebody else you know it strikes me as
given the time a lot of that it was
probably about a b
plus okay you know we forget
that nobody was well it's not true
nobody was planning for this but it
certainly wasn't what we expected to
come along
and when you've got to draw up something
like like this so quickly
and deal with the politics get it
through a very divided congress
i think we did actually reasonably well
up to the present where now again
we're arguing over what the next phase
of it ought to be yeah i mean i think
that
we can talk about the lack of pandemic
response readiness by the administration
on the more medical side getting rid of
the pandemic response team
ignoring the playbook etc but the shock
to the system from the economic side
would have been a shock regardless it
sounds like is what you're saying
i think that's true and i think there's
some things that seem superficially
attractive
that have some downsides so for example
the moratorium
on evictions and moratorium things it
makes perfectly you do not want to be
throwing people out on the street in the
middle of the pandemic
on the other hand you do have to
appreciate that those folks who are not
paying rent or not paying rent to other
small property owners who will then have
trouble so i you know i'm
much more comfortable with something
that substitutes for those rent payments
right so that there's no eviction and
therefore keeps the property owners
whole as opposed to just throwing the
thrust of the pain
on these small renters many of whom may
have just a couple of apartments that
are source of
revenue and if we say you can't a victim
but they're not paying you rent
then you've just created a different
level of distress
there is a perspective in economic
thinking
anytime you're talking about giving
people money this applies to
stimulus this applies to programs like
universal basic income
uh this applies to minimum wage
increases and the very general idea is
you devalue the currency when you when
you make it easier to get money when you
increase the supply of money
simple supply and demand suggests each
dollar becomes worth less
there's inflation and you end up
basically in the exact same place
can you talk now about the additional
knowledge we have
including from behavioral economics and
other types of economic thinking
that that makes that less cut and dry
well the one great puzzle of our time
pre-covered
is why we're not seeing more inflation
we have pumped
going back to the financial crisis up to
and including the coveted response we
have pumped
just staggering amounts of money and
liquidity
into the pipes and we're barely
reaching our inflation target targets
and sometimes
failing to reach our inflation target so
if you went back to grad school
when i was in grad school in the early
90s at the university of chicago and
said
hey let me give you a hypothetical
experiment where we pump
trillions of dollars into the economy do
you think you're going to get price
increases or maybe even a little
deflation
everybody would have said that is
impossible we're still trying to kind of
work through that
part of the behavioral economics
explanation just let me say
parenthetically i think
behavioral econ is one of the most
interesting and exciting things to come
along because
it helps to answer some of these
questions is that when you become
conditioned to stable prices for a long
period of time then it's harder to raise
prices it's the flip side of the 70s
when everyone just assumed hey we're
going to raise
i don't care what's going on the macro
my prices are going up 15
this year just because that's what you
do in spring you know maybe we're seeing
the back side of that
there's some discussion about whether
globalization has just continued to
increase the global supply
so much that we can absorb the money and
and spend it around the world and the
the competition from china and vietnam
keeps prices low because american firms
can't raise prices it just
keeps that constant pressure my
colleague here danny blanchflower
has argued that a lot of the labor
market data are very misleading
unemployment looks really low but when
you delve into it a lot of folks are not
working as many hours
as they would like to they're feeling
more tenuously attached to the labor
market
and then he's found this interesting
thing where if you ask people
how likely they are to be fired or lose
their job
they overstayed it by like five-fold
because you can then follow them and
find out how many of them are actually
fired
what that means is that they are very
reticent to ask for more money
because they feel that their job is more
precarious than it actually is and that
is another thing
keeping prices low so it's probably some
combination of these things
but i suspect that if you come up with
some unifying theory
of why all this money flowing into the
system hasn't led to more inflation you
will certainly be on the nobel short
list
well on on the other side of this
example that we're seeing
in i think in both naked economics and
money although you'll you'll correct me
you often use my birth country of
argentina
as an example of disasters when it comes
to currency i mean we've had we had
you know the peg the dollar peso peg
which completely
failed hyperinflation not at the level
of of like zimbabwe or venezuela but but
still
pretty bad all these terrible situations
when it comes to currency
what seems to be the tipping point where
those
cascading currency disasters happen in
countries i think the difference between
argentina and
most places in the world yeah is that
there's just not a lot of credibility
people don't believe the central bank
they don't believe the fiscal
authorities and a lot of monetary policy
is about credible commitment
that you say you're going to do
something you do it the markets respond
in ways that if they believe you
reinforce what's going to happen so when
the chair of the fed in the united
states says
we're serious about inflation we're not
going to get let prices rise faster than
two percent ever
well then people don't raise their
prices because they assume that the fed
would fight that back and
it becomes a self-reinforcing prophecy
when
the monetary authorities in argentina
say hey we're going to fight inflation
when everybody's done laughing they say
yeah yeah we've seen this movie 11 times
before
i don't i mean it's been a long time
since i wrote naked money
we were going to put a whole chapter on
argentina in instead we just used a lot
of examples
yeah that i'm glad you didn't do the
whole chapter that would have been that
would have been more devastating
um so so when it comes to um in in naked
money when you talk about the
credibility of money
as you're kind of talking about in the
context of argentina you do address
cryptocurrency and you
and you take head-on some of the um
bullet points that we hear
from some of the anti-cryptocurrency
people such as it doesn't have inherent
value and you explain
that you know the idea of gold having
inherent value
is also less clear maybe uh than than
some people point out
what's your sense now since the book was
written
about cryptocurrency we've seen you know
early in the pandemic
people expecting bitcoin to go crazy
were disappointed that it didn't but
then in the last few months we've
actually seen significant increase in
the in the value of bitcoin
what's your sense of it now i'm still
not very sold on the idea that bitcoin
is here for the long run
for a number of reasons i mean part of
you you expect bunny to do
a number of things and i don't think
bitcoin does any of them very well so
one
is as a unit of exchange and this is the
easiest one where it's clearly failed i
mean
part of the reason that we use dollars
and not argentine pesos is we have a
pretty good idea
of what the dollar is going to be worth
next year even ten years i mean maybe
plus or minus two percent but it really
doesn't move a whole lot
yeah when bitcoin right when people say
wow bitcoins on aurora it's up 400
that's not a good thing from the
standpoint of money now if you invested
in it you made a lot of money
but the point of money is i'm gonna buy
a house and i'm gonna say
you know david i'm gonna give you a
hundred bitcoins a year for the next 30
years that's the way a mortgage works
now if those bitcoins go up 400 percent
value my mortgage payment just went up
four percent so
it's very hard for us to contract using
a monetary
thing you know that's fluctuating but
even if it's going up you just want
something stable now
the other things that we look for are is
it a good store of value
that one i think is also uncertain yes
it's gained value but it's also
plummeted
at times on that one charles
after how many years of of at least it
retaining
some value would we be able to say that
the store of value requirement is met
i don't know if it's a number of years i
think it's the pers the percentage of
people who are persuaded that it will
hold its value
because as you correctly pointed out
it's all whether i believe that it has
value and if i do then i'll use it so
um certainly more than it used to yeah
um and
then the last one is kind of as a unit
of account or not as universal but as a
medium of exchange so
how easy is it to do transactions and
it's still much easier for me to use a
credit card or use
cash than it is for bitcoin i've got to
go buy the bitcoins and so
well i guess let me push back slightly
on that one in
in the last year i mean now just like my
credit card's linked up with my phone
and i can swipe it
i can link bitcoin with my phone with
instant dollar conversions and swipe it
the same way so it's definitely
changed a lot of progress has been made
and i would say you know if you're
in a place like venezuela or you're in a
place where
everything is just crumbling around you
then bitcoin might serve some of these
purposes better
than for me sitting here in new
hampshire right you've got to park
wealth someplace you got to move it
out of the country quickly so it
certainly has a purpose now
i'll add one other caveat that may be my
biggest concern
which is at present it's bitcoin is a
really handy medium of exchange for
people doing really nefarious things so
we just had a huge
hack of a hospital system in vermont
one of these ransomware things where
it's you know pay us x millions of
dollars
or will destroy all your systems and of
course the payment they want is in
bitcoin
which is terrific for them you know i do
have some concerns
from the bitcoin standpoint about if
this becomes the medium of exchange for
people doing bad
things then there might be some
regulatory crackdown on it
in which case it becomes less attractive
as a currency for everybody else
yeah that's interesting i mean i i i for
me the biggest concerns remain
uh in many cases transaction fees and
the the unpredictable
value the it's used for crime stuff i
mean when silk road was shut down which
was believed to be a huge piece of the
bitcoin market
the bit bitcoin market barely was
affected in number of transactions or
volume it seemed to be a much smaller
piece of it
and also by the way i mean most crimes
are are being committed involving
dollars most racketeering is happening
in dogs so that one is not
super strong for me but the logistics of
of it
and the volatility seem to be my biggest
concerns i don't know
yeah and you know i think bubbles are
interesting you never know
for sure if you're in a bubble until
it's over so in 2005
i thought the property prices were
frothy yeah but
i didn't short the property market it
would have been kind of hard to do
i also thought that amazon was wildly
overpriced
i was right on one of those things and
terribly wrong on the other
so you know i think time will tell but i
love the discussion because i think
bitcoin forces us to think about what
money is
why are the pieces of paper issued by
the argentine government
different than the pieces of paper
issued by the american government
because it's all just paper
thinking about the next five years
10 years what types of systemic
changes do you anticipate to economic
and financial systems that are a result
of
either technological change or cultural
change like the big picture things
i think the biggest question is what the
next phase of capitalism
looks like we're not going to go
socialist you know i'm old enough to
have lived through the soviet union i
traveled there i've been to cuba
that's not the future on the other hand
i think i teach a lot of young people
who look around and say well something's
not quite right i mean why is the
richest country in the history of
civilization why are people living
on the streets uh clearly what
the populace of both the left and the
right both trump and bernie
who when you parse it are saying some of
the same things
different policy but same similar
rhetoric yeah right so
exactly not the diagnosis is broadly
similar
they are reflecting the fact that
despite great wealth and over the
my lifetime enormous growth in the
economy and incomes
people feel very insecure and they feel
not fully happy with the level of
disruption and of course we're looking
at a.i
and other things coming down the pike so
i think the question
for people who are right and center left
so not the socialist not the nationalist
populous
is how do we tighten the safety net
so that the folks who we know are being
disrupted or will be disrupted
can kind of bounce back into this
vibrant growing economy without just
hitting the ground
and interestingly i think you know
center left has always talked about this
when you look at the scandinavian
countries they're they're actually
robust capitalist economies yes they
just have a tighter safety net
right but i think it's going to become
more interesting for center right there
are folks like orrin cass who's a
conservative thinker
who's talking more about the role that
unions might play from a conservative
standpoint
to give workers more voice i think
there's going to be a lot of fresh
thinking about how we harness everything
that is great about capitalism
and there's a lot there while we sew
the holes up that are clearly the the
failures and deficiencies
or in cass i'll have to i'll have to
just do a little reading up
hey before i let you go i recently read
the book
station 11 by emily st john mandel which
is
pandemic literature and also beautiful
writing
absolutely fantastic book fantastic book
uh you've
written the rationing also uh about a
global pandemic this is like a genre now
pandemic literature
lawrence wright who's another terrific
writer wrote a book
i think the end of october which is
about a pandemic so yes my book the
rationing is about
who gets the vaccine right during a
pandemic and
just to point out it was written in 2019
yes so yes it is
you know part of the reason it's a genre
is the same reason that
apocalypse movies are a genre is we're
fascinated
by how we behave as humans in adverse
circumstances that's why we watch war
movies over and over again
so it wasn't that it was a genius about
the pandemic that was just a convenient
tool
right for looking at the political
response it's really a political
thriller
that's the rationing we've been speaking
with charles whelan professor of public
policy at dartmouth
also check out the naked books naked
economics naked money naked statistics i
i so appreciate your time today
oh it's great to talk to you the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
i have a very strange video that is
quickly becoming one of my favorite
clips of the week this is
i don't even know how to explain this
donald trump did
an event yesterday instead of just
hiding it was good to see him do
something he did a presidential medal of
freedom ceremony for dan
gable who's a wrestler and coach and as
the event was
sort of winding down the press assembled
and was starting to ask trump questions
and in the video i'm going to play for
you you will hear a question asked
of donald trump about whether he will go
to joe biden's inauguration
and trump just sort of looked around
confused i guess
realized he didn't want to answer that
question and just walked out of the room
and you can tell from the video that
people are confused about why donald
trump is leaving
and the camera weirdly cuts to dan gable
who's the presidential medal honoree
who looks very confused and says
he's gone because clearly no one
expected such an abrupt ending to this
event it's some of the strangest
behavior we've seen
um take a look at this it's just
absolute gold
mr president one more question about the
inauguration thank you very much
it really seems like the curvier
enthusiasm theme should be playing as
donald trump one
walks out it's comical and bizarre
and unexplainable all at once and the
simplest explanation is trump's
trump continues not to want to answer
questions like
do you admit you lost and do you concede
that joe biden will be president
and will you be going to the
inauguration and there was really no way
to stay in the room without
answering the questions as far as trump
was concerned but the truth is
a real president could have handled this
very easily
and stayed in the room without answering
those questions trump could have said
hey listen guys we're here today to
honor
dan we're celebrating dan's incredible
accomplishments i don't know what they
are but but he
presumably does i'm just not familiar
with dan gable
and he could say this isn't a time for
politics
it's not a time for questions thank you
very much you're still avoiding the
questions but you're doing it in a
slightly more reasonable way
trump can't do it or at least he doesn't
behave in that way and
instead just kind of bizarrely wanders
off leaving
a room full of people and everything
about this event was was a total farce
at one point while the event is going on
there's a little kid laying
down looks like he's sleeping in the
back of the oval office or whatever room
this was in
all completely bizarre and of course
trump supporters will defend him no
matter what and say well listen
the fake news media was throwing unfair
mean questions at him it was
presidential harassment
and uh if you think that's crazy
dan gable was actually interviewed this
morning about this bizarre event
and he essentially said that which was
trump didn't want to answer those
questions
truly strange times take a look i think
donald trump
really respects me he's always been
humbled in front of me
he's never made me mad he might have
walked out of the press conference a
little bit
yesterday a little bit perturbed with a
couple
newspaper newspaper people but but hey i
was having a great time
he left you in the office by yourself
with your family
that's okay he uh he uh he was didn't
like what was going on
he thought he said it was about me and
it wasn't about him so he's
i'm out of there you got it no i hear
you and you have the medal with you
i i certain i do right here can we see
it right here yep
uh yeah right here it's the it's uh
president's medal of freedom right here
yeah
so uh what a weird timeline that we are
in
and um i know some people have been
writing to me saying
trump is comedy gold david i'm really
going to miss
trump when he leaves office stuff like
this
i guess is funny in a relatively benign
way
and i will sort of miss it but the
country and the world are going to be so
much better off with trump gone and
we're down to just six weeks we're all
looking forward to it
now speaking of being down to just six
weeks since joe biden's inauguration
we learned about something crazy
yesterday donald trump
now that he seems to slowly be accepting
although he won't admit it
privately he seems to be accepting that
he lost to joe biden
trump is reportedly planning an
absolutely
bonkers inauguration day stunt for
january 20th now
as you might remember from past
inaugurations there's this tradition
where the incoming president allows the
outgoing president as they leave the
white house
to fly wherever they're going on air
force one
uh barack obama stood there uh and saw
george w bush and laura bush off on
inauguration day
into marine one helicopter and over to
air force one to go
i believe it was back to texas uh donald
trump likewise saw barack and michelle
obama off on
inauguration day on to the helicopter
bringing them to air force one to go i
don't actually remember exactly
where they went in fact maybe barack
obama was
i think he stayed in dc for school
purposes for his kids but maybe he went
to chicago initially or something like
that anyway
even though donald trump has still not
publicly acknowledged that joe biden won
nor has he or anyone else said that he
would attend joe biden's inauguration on
january 20th
trump is reportedly planning to fly to
florida on air force one
to do a competing event to joe biden's
inauguration can you imagine anything
more corrosive to democracy
beyond the things that donald trump has
been doing for the last month and for
the last four years
what could be more corrosive to
democracy on inauguration day for your
successor
than being the outgoing president and
holding
a competing rally likely to claim
either that he actually won as joe biden
is being inaugurated
or to announce his candidacy for 2024
as joe biden is being inaugurated and
part of the reason that it's corrosive
to democracy
is that it will continue to push a
portion of the country's voters to
believe as they already do
that joe biden as of january 20th will
be an
illegitimate president in some way now
the truth could not be further from that
claim
joe biden not only won electorally with
the same
allegedly landslide victory that donald
trump claimed for himself in 2016.
but instead of losing the popular vote
by nearly 3 million as trump did in 2016
joe biden won by 6-7
is it maybe even 8 million votes at this
point in time
so a former president being dropped off
by air force one on inauguration day
for a rally at which he will claim to be
the real winner
will not exactly project the stability
of american democracy and in fact it
will project
much of the opposite now rally aside an
outgoing president
boycotting the incoming president's
inauguration that alone would be bad
enough now
i don't think joe biden cares biden has
already said
his concern is that it would be
meaningful to america
for trump to be there and really see
through
a fully peaceful transfer of power biden
doesn't personally care and i really
don't either
the other wrinkle is again to go back to
the other possibility
that donald trump announces his 2024
candidacy
on inauguration day and these two things
really could be the same one in other
words
trump might fly to a rally in florida
at which he makes this announcement
while claiming he actually
won and it was stolen from him now
whatever happens what we can be sure of
is number one
trump won't behave like an adult on
inauguration day and two
it will be really embarrassing for the
country and three
his supporters will absolutely love it
trump will prove once again that
there is no floor to his petulant nature
there's no too far
for donald trump and of course part of
the whole point would be
to take audience away from joe biden do
you think
that if trump does a january 20th rally
at the same time as the inauguration
do you think cnn will cover both in a
split screen
will msnbc cover both in a split screen
i don't know
i think the bigger question is if trump
does this
does oan even cover the inauguration
does newsmax even cover the fact that
there's a new president being sworn in
or do they only cover trump's bizarre
rally
we'll eventually find out what trump is
doing we can rest easy knowing that
whatever the hell he's doing
at noon on january 20th he will no
longer be doing it as president
and the other story that we're hearing
is that donald trump does indeed plan to
go down to florida to his resort
for christmas and there are rumors which
we've heard for weeks now there are
rumors that trump will never come back
to the white house that trump is
abandoning the white house uh at
christmas time
and won't even come back which would uh
make irrelevant this entire idea
of flying out on air force one might
still hold the rally
on inauguration day needless to say the
next six weeks are going to be
completely wacky
here's a funny voicemail we received our
voicemail line of course
is 219 to david p
this caller is asking is rudy giuliani
on the basis of his recent covet
diagnosis
sort of like typhoid mary take a listen
to this
hi david this is gary from oregon again
do you ever consider that rudy
giuliani was sent around
as typhoid mary to
mess up all of these states arizona
nevada blah blah blah
in their government so that they had to
close down or shut down
i wouldn't put it past donald trump and
he's not
my president yeah i wouldn't put it past
trump
morally this idea of hey maybe
if we get rudy coveted positive and send
him around
and shut down state legislatures maybe
it'll interfere with electoral votes
being formally voted on on december 14th
it's number one the timing of it doesn't
make sense rudy's been flying around for
a month doing this
and he likely was only contagious as of
last thursday now
he did by exposing the arizona
legislature
get the arizona legislature shut down
but um
no i think number one the timing doesn't
make sense
number two i don't think they're really
that organized and number three
i don't think it even would plausibly
impact the december 14th electoral vote
because it doesn't really depend on
state legislatures i mean it would
theoretically depend on state
legislatures if they want to try to
interfere and send different electors it
doesn't appear anybody's going to do
that so
morally you're completely right i
wouldn't put it past trump but it
requires too much organization for
thought and it's not really a good plan
anyway
we have a great bonus show for you today
congress is daring donald trump to veto
their defense spending bill
where is that fight going to end up the
fouchy effect
has led to medical school applications
jumping
18 during the pandemic very interesting
and donald trump's attorney general
william barr days after there were
rumors that trump may
fire barr is reportedly himself
considering resignation
before the end of donald trump's term
what would that achieve anyway at this
late stage of the game we will discuss
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
get instant access by signing up at
joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
if you're trying to quit smoking or
vaping check out lucy which is a
nicotine gum developed by
caltech scientists they'll ship it right
to your door and you can save 20 percent
when you go to lucy.co and use coupon
code pacman
magic spoon is the cereal that tastes
exactly like the delicious cereals from
your childhood except it has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect for a keto diet
to get free shipping go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman blinkist
is the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman